migration is illumination long awaited
film about a quirky family of ducks on a
New York City Adventure the film had
some delays over the years the cast
worked in complete isolation and there
were a ton of real life attributes taken
from the actors themselves and put into
the film one thing that's interesting
about animation is that the cast very
rarely ever gets to meet or work
together migration was no different
everyone was just Solo in a booth most
of them didn't meet until the movies
Premiere I just met my son and daughter
for the first time um we didn't do any
of this work together even with that
isolation though the cast did get to see
each other's work while the movie was
being made it was helpful when figuring
out how to play off of each other's
characters the film also took a lot
longer than you probably think it did 5
years to be exact which was one of the
reasons why the date of the film got
pushed back more on that coming up
finally be able to share it with the
world and the animation is beautiful
there's a reason it takes a long time
Universal Studios made the unusual
decision given the film's plot to push
the release date back from the summer of
2023 to Winter a big reason for this
push back was actually because of Co the
film was in its production stage for a
really long time it wasn't the worst
decision though as now they're hoping to
capitalize on the audience's desire for
summer entertainment during the cold
months of winter migration is now set to
be released in December 2023 among other
highly anticipated titles Aquaman and
the lost kingdom the iron claw and Wonka
though the film has a lot of competition
everyone has the bar pretty high for
migration because of Illumination recent
work they really changed the game with
Despicable Me sing and their most recent
film The Super Mario Brothers movie so
even with major delays and push back all
that means is that everything about
migration is going to be cultivated to
Perfection the director Benjamin rener
wanted to make sure that seeing this
film in theaters would be an immersive
experience I wanted to reward the
audience with like this beautiful
scenery that you can have when you do
this kind of effort of going out Keegan
Michael Key was really excited about
this role because one of his favorite
things to do while performing is dialect
work he had also never gotten to play a
Jamaican character yet throughout the
course of his career obviously being new
to the accent he did run into a bit of
struggle more specifically he would
often end up sounding a bit Irish you
find yourself going to Lucky Charms
instead of being in N Jama he had to
redo a lot of takes when you try to stay
in a in AA type of dialect you know what
I'm saying there man okay according to
the voice actors doing animation can be
a lot easier than acting on camera I
think you're allowed to overact a little
bit because you're trying to match the
look of the characters the actors are
allowed to be generous with their body
language and facial expressions which is
helpful with breathing life into your
animated character while you're all
alone in a booth Keegan Michael Key was
grateful he was able to put so much of
his personality into his character while
being given the grace to overact quite
the opposite of his usual on camera
roles which are always bigger than life
or exaggerated and so that you get to
put more of yourself into it speaking of
putting a lot of yourself into a
character often times in animated films
the animated team pulls real life looks
and traits from the actors and puts them
right into the film itself the pigeon
like has my eyelashes I don't know how
to describe it this is aquafina's fourth
or fifth bird she's played in her career
but chump is the most interesting of
them all the way that they kind of work
in you and the character is always
really cool Benjamin rener heavily
influenced the film's voice and
character Direction not only as a
director but also as an actor like I
mentioned before most of the cast didn't
get to meet throughout the production
which includes Benjamin Keegan Michael
Key hadn't gotten to meet him at all
until the movie's premiere didn't even
know what the guy looked like one thing
Benjamin loved doing was the character's
voices so he would put things into the
film and and we would get to listen to
him regardless of having to do most of
his Communications with the main cast
Over Zoom he felt really connected to
them and thought they were all perfect
fits for their characters when I met
them for the first time they really wear
the characters I told them like just be
natural the natural characters the
detailed animation and the effortless
comedy the cast and director bring to
this film are completely unmatched
pushing through 5 years of delay and
taking over the Christmas season as a
summer family flick migration is
definitely going to want to be on your
watch list this
winter